hi there Steve here about halfway
through my Korean challenge and it's
difficult to stay on task because now
with my wife's bunion operation so she's
immobile so I'm having to do the cooking
and I'm enjoying it so I put a lot of
time into it like this evening I made a
TIA which is a dish from southern France
which is one of my favourite places in
terms of cooking and also for visiting
and it was I had you know the zucchini
an eggplant and the fennel and that
sliced thin with some snapper that
whatever I went up to buy whatever they
had that was on special fish wise at the
supermarket
so they had some snapper so I chopped
that up into small pieces mix that in
amongst the vegetables with you know oil
and garlic and whatnot and it was very
good I enjoyed it but it ends up taking
a lot of time between that and oh and as
an hors d'oeuvre we still have a little
bit of ravioli left over and I also made
some asparagus and to go with the
ravioli so that was our our hors
d'oeuvre followed by the teal and I
won't go into all the other dishes that
I've been preparing but I can assure you
that it's a three hour operation from
beginning to end including the cleanup
so this last time for studying Korean
but I stay with my Korean every minute
that I can squeeze just before bed or
whatever I go and continue to do my
Korean and that's the advantage of being
in one of these 90 day challenges you
kind of feel you can't let it slip
because you know how far I'm gonna get I
don't think I'm gonna achieve the goals
that I originally set in terms of number
of links created new words known and
stuff but I do sense that I'm getting a
better handle on the language but today
I would thought I would talk about cuz
you know the other thing that distracts
you is always the American election and
Donald Trump and all that stuff and so
you end up watching some of that on TV
following some of it on Twitter so I was
thinking of Donald Trump as a language
learner how would he do I really thought
this all out but I guess just gonna
ramble on I think he would do very
poorly and there are a number of reasons
first of all to learn a language another
language you have to be interested and
my impression is that
the Donald Trump isn't interested in
much outside of himself so to learn the
language you've actually gotta say Jesus
I'm interested in that culture I'm
interested in that language I'm
interested in those people maybe I want
to imitate those people I want to be
like those people I want to live like
those people at least to some extent
that's all part of transporting yourself
into that other language environment he
ain't gonna do that next thing is
language learning takes time therefore
you have to you have to find the time
and when you're doing it you have to be
focused and I think Donald has a very
limited attention span so for him to
actually stay on task to read something
looking up words that he doesn't
understand listening to things that he
doesn't understand in order to gradually
you know over time get a better better
handle on that language I don't see it
ah what else is there you know you have
to I think there's an element to in
language learning of respect you have to
respect the language and you have to I
think respect the culture Donald doesn't
even respect his own culture he doesn't
respect the Democratic traditions the
Constitution the separation of powers
you know respect for the individual
there's no respect there's just Donald
and whatever he can impose on people so
no respect no attention no attention
span lack of interest let's see what
else
energy level he has at least what
appears to be the case watching him I
don't know maybe he goes back and
crashes in his room I don't know you
have to connect with people you have to
connect with people you have to enjoy
that connection with people across
language barriers and a connection which
is largely a give-and-take in fact
language learning is more about
listening than speaking because you have
to get it from someone else
you can't just start talking you
actually have to listen in order to hear
how the language is used you may say a
few things or you may not say a few
things but you have to get it in from
other people so you have to be a good
listener which I don't think is one of
his strengths you know I don't think he
connects with people and listens and
then responds to what they're saying and
establishes that connect just doesn't
happen it's all about him prancing
around so for all of those reasons I
suspect the dumb Trump would be a very
poor language learner we'd love to have
him on link but I don't think it would
work out for Donald anyway that was a
short evaluation of Donald UMP dad
dumped Donald Trump the language learner
bye for now